أجنبي
يمكنك في كثير من الأحيان مقارنته بالزجاج ،
لذا فهو قوي جدًا ، يمكنك فعل الكثير
به ، ولكن إذا كسرته ،
يمكن أن يأتي صدع كامل مثل البرق
قبل أن تضع الصودا اللطيفة
أقل مثل هذا ، فلا بأس في الوقت الحاضر
كل شيء يحتاج إلى  كن مثاليًا ، لا
يمكن أن يكون الاختلاف في التناظر سوى
نقطة صفر معينة ، أي شيء في المائة
بشكل أساسي خلال الـ 25 عامًا الماضية ، فقد
تغير التخطيط الكامل للماس والتصنيع بالكامل بشكل كبير قبل أن تمنح
الماس إلى القاطع ، الملمع الرئيسي
الآن  منذ وصول بعض
آلات التخطيط الدقيقة ، يتعين على
المهندسين الأصغر سنًا أن
يخبروا كبار السن في كثير من الأحيان
كيف يحتاجون إلى تلميع كيف يحتاجون إلى
الرسم بقلم الرصاص بين
السطور التي حددناها بشكل
أساسي ،
وسوف نتلقى الماس الخام
سنفحص أول مرة ثم
نعطيها للصانع
لمصنع التلميع ، وسوف يقومون بتلميع بعض الجوانب ،
ثم يقوم زملائي هنا بعمل
خريطة ثلاثية الأبعاد كاملة لماسة
التضمينات والعيوب ،
ثم سنقوم بتشغيل  خوارزمية لمعرفة
أعلى قيمة ممكنة يمكن
إخراجها من هذا الحجر ،
فنحن نركز حقًا على هذا المكان المناسب من
الألماس عالي القيمة إذا نظرت إلى مقدار
القيمة التي نتلقاها هنا ، أعتقد أنه سنويًا
حوالي 50 مليون دولار
اعتادوا الذهاب إلى
أنتويرب ، فهم جميعًا أشخاص من جميع أنحاء
العالم من هونغ كونغ إلى
نيويورك ، جاءوا إلى أنتويرب لرؤية
الماس وفحصهم
الآن ، جميع المناقصات تنتقل بشكل أساسي
إلى دبي ، لذا فقد بدأت دبي مؤخرًا
نمت حقًا بطريقة لا تصدق من حيث
المواد الخام التي يتم استيرادها على الأرجح
قبل 10 سنوات ، لقد استوردوا
50 مما فعلته أنتويرب الآن
وأصبحوا أكبر [
موسيقى]
بعض الأشخاص لديهم صلات مباشرة مع
رجل في إفريقيا يمتلك بعض الأشخاص منجمًا
نحصل على الكثير من الماس الذي
تم قطعه تاريخيًا ، دعنا نقول قبل 30 عامًا ،
ولكن الجودة المرغوبة
للعميل النهائي قد تغيرت كثيرًا ، لذلك قمنا
أيضًا بإعادة عدد كبير جدًا من
الأعمال المثيرة
[الموسيقى]
لذا فإن العملية  يستغرق
الانتهاء من الماس تمامًا
يعتمد بشكل كبير على حجم
الحجر لإعطائك فكرة أن هذا مكون من
90 حرفًا وهذا حجر استثنائي جدًا ،
وقد يستغرق هذا الأمر ما يصل إلى
شهرين بسهولة للقيام به
العملية برمتها والتي ليست دائمًا سهلة لأن
أسعار الماس متذبذبة للغاية ،
فنحن بحاجة إلى القيام بعمل دقيق ومثالي
لأنه لا توجد طريقة للعودة إلى الماس
بمجرد أن تقوم بتلميع
الوجه الذي لا يمكنك لصق أي شيء عليه.
عندما نتحدث عن
الاتجاهات الحديثة أه الأحجار البيضاء الكبيرة مثل هذه ،
فهي تميل إلى الانخفاض قليلاً في
السعر جيدًا إذا نظرت إلى الماس الوردي
والماس الأزرق ، فإنها تحافظ على ارتفاع
الأسعار بشكل لا يصدق
بالطريقة التي ننظر بها هنا إلى مصنعنا
كثيرًا.  قارنها بسباق الفورمولا 1 ،
لذا فأنت بحاجة إلى أفضل سيارة تحتاج إلى
أفضل سائق وتحتاج إلى أفضل فريق
خلفك لأن كل هذه المعدات
متوفرة في السوق فهي
متوفرة منذ 15 عامًا ولكن إذا كنت تقود
سيارة فورمولا 1  وأنت لست
متسابقًا متمرسًا لا يمكنك الفوز بأي
سباق